is there a device you can give to young
people
instead of high school college
you know thinking about their career
thinking about life
how to live one they're proud of
i think the the number one thing
[Music]
i can tell people is and how i've lived
my life is
you've really got to like forget
everybody in your life right now your
mother your father your grandparents
your girlfriend your boyfriend whoever
it is and really decide like
what is going to make you happy
right at some point in my career
the act of pushing my body to the limit
made me happier
than winning a grand slam medal
pushing my body to the limit didn't make
me happier than winning an olympic medal
right there was a there's a balance
there
and i think a lot of people struggle
with living their life where they're
happy and they make other people
happy or take in their
their feelings into the considerations
of what they need to do in their life
and i think if they can cut those
strings
sooner
and it'll allow you to get over it
quicker and get to a happier place
sooner
and then as long as you're focusing on
what's making you happy
the things you do that make you happy
will attract other people who do those
things that will in turn build stronger
better relationships
and then you will also
realize the
the best form of yourself and inspire
many others like yeah you've
inspired me
to uh for whatever the hell i've done
uh at least to do a slightly better job
than i otherwise would have by doing
martial arts but taking that uh journey
and i think becoming a better person
because of it so travis i have been i
continue to be
one of your biggest fans i love your
whole career in the way you pursued
happiness i love what you and jimmy have
done i love the support of judo as
represented by you so i deeply
appreciate what you've done man and i'm
honored that you would uh spend your
time with me today thanks for talking
man thank you
you